what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and multiverse of
madness is less than two weeks away now
and for those who have been asking yes i
am going to the premiere next monday a
week from today and of course it comes
out everywhere on the 6th and i think a
lot of people are probably seeing it the
5th or the 4th right before the release
day because theaters allow you to do
that but today we're going to talk about
the fact that it's been revealed that
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness has added scenes and has taken
scenes out based off of the request of
marvel studios so the mcu can connect a
little bit more i've been getting a lot
of questions about this so we'll talk
about it in this video and it's actually
quite good if you're thinking about the
entirety of the mcu it is good now of
course this means that there could have
been some cameos taken out and some
cameos put in the film that weren't
originally supposed to be there or that
originally were there and now aren't but
let's talk about what this means and if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
stay up to date on the latest mcu news
so bruce campbell who of course has been
with marvel for a pretty long time most
people recall him from the original
spider-man trilogy he's confirmed to be
in multiverse of madness and it's widely
believed that he is actually going to be
playing a doctor strange variant yes we
have seen doctor strange variants who
look the same but remember what loki
taught us some can look the same and
some can look completely different and
actually have different powers and
abilities so we'll have to see exactly
who he's playing but here is what he
recently came out and said not too long
ago last week about some edits of the
movie he said the marvel guys they make
eight of these movies at the same time
so they're always updating storylines so
my buddy sam raimi has had to add scenes
that marvel told him he had to shoot and
he's removed scenes that no longer apply
now there's a little bit of controversy
surrounding this right now because a lot
of people view movies as movies of the
director and yes obviously the director
is a massive part of the movie and an
extremely important person but remember
it's the studio who is actually
producing the movie it's their film and
when we have marvel studios who has a
connected universe sometimes they're
going to need certain things to connect
and sometimes it won't matter a perfect
example is moon knight that is out on
disney plus right now that doesn't
connect to the mcu really at all and the
directors and screenwriters have
expressed plenty of times by now that
that was a really good thing about it
that it doesn't really connect to
anything else it stands alone so for
that instance marvel gave them the
freedom to kind of do whatever they want
but then you have a movie that's so huge
like doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness that's going to affect the
mcu in its entirety and the entire
multiverse so its impact is obviously
bigger than moon knights think about it
this could set up the x-men this could
introduce the fantastic four this could
bring deadpool into the mcu this is huge
and i mean it's called the multiverse of
madness of course it's going to connect
and affect other mcu properties so yes
as movies evolve as scripts evolve and
stories evolve kevin feige has ultimate
say on whatever happens and maybe thor
love and thunder is going to do
something very specific that they kind
of need to tweak something in multiverse
of madness which just makes sense now
sometimes this can kind of interfere
with the direction of the film as many
know scott derrickson who directed the
first doctor strange film was also
supposed to direct doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness as well and based
off of what we know he parted ways with
marvel studios based off of creative
differences we know that he wanted this
to be a horror film and was probably
pushing the boundaries of pg-13 and heck
he probably wanted it to be rated r and
that's where from what we know kevin
feige kind of said no we're not really
going to do that it can have horror type
aspects to it but it's still going to be
a marvel movie and it's still going to
be pg-13 and at the same time he
probably told him that some things had
to happen in the movie to set up other
things that are going to take place in
the mcu and from what we know the
difference between what the studio
wanted and what the director wanted led
to the fallout that's not confirmed but
that is what is widely speculated with
all of the outlets but overall it is
really good for the entirety of the mcu
what makes the mcu fantastic is that it
does all interconnect we can have
avengers movies where you have a bunch
of different heroes come together in a
epic movie avengers in-game was
incredible spider-man no way home was
incredible marvel knows what they're
doing so yes sometimes they say hey this
movie has to do this but let's remember
it's marvel's movie it's marvel's
universe and of course the exciting
thing is that may include some pretty
big cameos we know professor x and the
illuminati is going to be in the
multiverse of madness now before this
was confirmed rumors had been going
around for a pretty long time which
means that this was probably always part
of marvel's plan so it looks like it was
kevin feige's call to introduce a lot of
these new major characters to the mcu
even if they are variants they still set
up these characters to appear in the
future somewhere and if there was a
really really big cameo that was going
to be so big that the fans would just
love it i doubt kevin feige would have
them take out that cameo what was most
likely taken out were some scenes that
didn't really have anything to do with
the continuity of the mcu which is most
likely another good thing because we
don't want to be confused so don't worry
about these changes they are most likely
really really good and based off of what
we've seen from sam raimi he seems to be
very very happy with how the movie came
out so who's ready for multiverse
madness let me know how excited you are
in the comments below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest news
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof
me